[Música]
seria cumple 10 años desde el inicio de
las revueltas en contra del gobierno de
bashar al-assad que llevaron a una
sangrienta guerra civil que ha cobrado
la vida de más de medio millones de
personas una década después hay 56
millones de refugiados y 67 millones de
desplazados internos
en mi llamar las autoridades continúan
asesinando manifestantes 10 personas
murieron hoy al menos 50 fallecieron el
domingo en el día más sangriento de la
represión de las movilizaciones desde el
golpe de estado del primero de febrero
entre los desmanes desde el domingo hubo
ataques contra 32 empresas chinas lo que
provocó la extensión de la ley marcial
y en bolivia la justicia ordenó cuatro
meses de prisión preventiva para la
detenida ex presidenta interina jeanine
áñez y dos de sus exministros acusados
de participar en un golpe de estado que
obligó a la renuncia de evo morales- en
2019 tras unas elecciones fallidas se
prepara en marchas a favor y en contra
de la medida
regresamos con ustedes para actualizar
la información más importante de américa
latina y del mundo hoy se cumple el
décimo aniversario de la guerra de siria
una de las más cruentas de la historia
reciente en marzo del 2011 empezaron las
movilizaciones pro democracia que
inicialmente fueron pacíficas pero que
luego llevaron a un conflicto que ahora
involucra actores regionales e
internacionales una década después de
más de medio millón de personas han
muerto hay 56 millones de refugiados y
6,7 millones de desplazados internos que
viven rodeados de ruinas y pobreza
bashar al-assad sigue en el poder
controlando grandes partes del país
árabe respaldado por rusia y por las
milicias chiítas de irán en traca una de
las ciudades más golpeadas por la guerra
está nuestra enviada especial de
catalina gómez ángel con el reporte de
cómo vive la población hoy cada vez más
sumida en la pobreza y con una economía
colapsada
a nivel
de que más de la mitad
[Música]
los salarios ya no les alcanzan para
nada el poder de adquisición es mínimo
lo que lleva mucha gente a buscar ayuda
en organizaciones vuelta
gracias en el país especialmente tienes
como raza
mucha gente las familias más pobres
yendo a buscar comida porque no tienen
con qué comprar y cada momento se nos
acercan papel y gente
[Música]
es más pobre lo que preocupa a las
autoridades porque esto
ideologías como grupos extremistas como
el estado islámico que una ideología en
sí represente en una ciudad como raha
especialmente con esas células urbanas
que pueden aparecer en cualquier momento
vamos al análisis con ariel gonzález
eleva allí desde el centro de estudios
internacionales de la universidad
católica argentina buen día señor ariel
gracias por acompañarnos y algunos ya
hablan de posguerra bashar al-assad
retomó el control de grandes áreas del
país pero eeuu aún controlan zonas
petroleras y de producción de trigo
turquía domina cerca de su frontera eso
sin contar los remanentes del estado
islámico la guerra ya terminó
y desangelada creo que todavía la de la
guerra no ha terminado
hay varias todavía enclaves las cuales
están todavía tiene que recuperar tanto
en inglés como en el noreste controlado
por digamos los sectores kurdos por lo
tanto creo que todavía siguen estamos
entrando en la fase final
afortunadamente faltan una serie de
pasos que tienen que ver con el arreglo
institucional de la silla tipo guerra el
cual parece ser bastante desafiante no
sólo por la intención de ver antes de
continuar el poder sino también por la
y complejidad de actores regionales e
internacionales involucrados después de
una década de guerra no solamente se
mantiene el dolor constante de la
mayoría de la población que ha perdido a
sus seres queridos también está ariel la
angustia de una crisis económica que
empeora los precios de los alimentos el
colapso de la moneda la escasez de los
servicios públicos y de la gasolina como
podrá bashar al-assad subsanar las
consecuencias del conflicto que no logró
sacarlo del poder
bueno creo que hoy en día hay avanzada
tiene dos desafíos importantes además de
obviamente las consecuencias desde el
conflicto armado el primero tiene que
ver con la actuación de kobe 19 entre la
población eso está tensionando aún más
el débil sistema de salud y en segundo
lugar las consecuencias económicas de
una crisis de que se desarrolle en un
marco de una economía de guerra economía
devastada y esto creo que es
lamentablemente requiere que los todos
los involucrados también los organismos
internacionales presionen al gobierno de
al assad para comenzar un proceso de
reconstrucción decidía que va a ser una
de las claves
de la posguerra una vez que los
conflictos del conflicto interno
finalice pero todavía esta es una
película que está el final está por
verse y finalmente más de la mitad de
los ciudadanos fueron forzosamente
desplazados del país miles de
desaparecidos y más de medio millón de
muertos pero la justicia no llega para
ellos apenas hay una sentencia en el
extranjero por crímenes de lesa
humanidad como podría acabar este
estancamiento en la búsqueda de la
reparación para la gente
bueno soy bastante escéptico en relación
a que luego de este este largo conflicto
haya justicia
como lo vimos en otros conservados como
en la labia o en ruanda porque aquí el
sistema no ha caído no debemos pasar la
sal y los principales componentes de las
fuerzas armadas y de seguridad el signo
del poder entonces realmente va a ser
muy difícil ver a tenemos un régimen que
sigue en el poder y que seguramente
debido a que en definitiva a pesar que
está muy debilitado ha triunfado en
relación a los rosarenses diferentes
grupos por lo tanto es muy difícil que
esto lleve demasiados pasos más allá de
lo visto momento hasta ahora gracias a
usted por sus impresiones y durante esta
semana les entregaremos una serie de
informes de los refugiados sirios en
diferentes países
el informe de hoy es en turquía que
comparte frontera con siria y que acoge
a cerca de 4 millones de refugiados más
que ningún otro país en el mundo entre
ellos muchos jóvenes que no saben a
futuro en su tierra natal y que están
desilusionados por las promesas rotas de
la revolución esta es la historia de ola
en estambul
[Música]
me llamo ola de hours y vengo de damasco
tengo 26 años llegué a turquía en marzo
de 2015
hola trata de llevar la vida de
cualquier joven de su edad actualmente
está estudiante que sueña con ser
arquitecta del paisaje está grabando un
vídeo para los cerca de 20.000 inscritos
a su cuenta de youtube
aquí puedo pensar en mi hacer cosas para
mí cosas que me gustan y que eran
difíciles de realizar en siria por
ejemplo tengo mi cuenta de vídeos y
youtube
me hace falta mi casa mi hermana mis
amigos mi familia todos están allá no
tengo televisión y no veo noticias
cuando quiero saber qué está pasando en
siria le pregunto a mi hermana oa mis
amigos trato de mantener la distancia
porque cuando hablan decir en la
televisión me siento mal me siento
triste no tiene esperanzas para siria
lo que sí creo que la situación va a
mejorar no está mal
ni me lo pregunto ni lo pienso tampoco
cojear me vale
o la fue escogida para participar en un
cortometraje que cuenta la historia de
una siria que se adapta a un nuevo país
aquí la gente tiene prejuicios muy
arraigados en contra de los sirios por
ejemplo cuando voy a visitar un
apartamento la gente me ve se da cuenta
de que soy una persona de bien pero no
me lo quieren arrendar porque soy sirio
no
mas alderney no no quiero volver a sirio
porque allá no podría cumplir mis sueños
mi país es incapaz de asegurar lo mínimo
necesario para sus habitantes si no
hubiera habido guerra mi vida habría
sido tan diferente creo que me habría
conformado con una vida sencilla sin
peligros sin miedo hacia el futuro
mi amor vivió el fin de semana más
sangriento desde el golpe de estado al
menos 50 personas murieron en las calles
y este lunes ellas son seis muertos a
manos de las fuerzas de seguridad entre
los desmanes del domingo hubo ataques
incendiarios contra 32 empresas
financiadas por china en este país que
hicieron que los militares se
extendieran la ley marcial en rangún
un completo caos en las calles de rangún
se desató cuando las fuerzas de
seguridad abrieron fuego contra los
manifestantes resultando en uno de los
días más violentos de manifestaciones
desde que comenzó el golpe militar en mi
amarte a última hora del domingo los
medios estatales anunciaron que el
ejército había declarado la ley marcial
en dos municipios de rangún
el consejo de administración del estado
otorga al comandante regional de rangún
el poder administrativo y judicial de
ley marcial sobre dos municipios en la
región de rangún lo que le permite al
mando militar de la región hacer cumplir
la seguridad hacer cumplir el estado de
derecho y garantizar la tranquilidad de
manera más eficaz la medida se produjo
después de que china le pidiera a
mianmar que protegiera los intereses y a
las personas de su nación luego de que
algunas de sus fábricas fueran
incendiadas por desconocidos muchos
manifestantes creen que china está
brindando apoyo en la junta militar la
represión por parte de las fuerzas de
seguridad ha dejado decenas de
manifestantes muertos desde el
derrocamiento del gobierno elegido
democráticamente y se estima que más de
2.000 personas han sido
tenemos que luchar por nuestro futuro no
acepto el golpe militar a veces corremos
y nos escondemos de la violencia una vez
más me arrestaron pero la gente vino a
ayudarme a escapar de las fuerzas de
seguridad y fui liberado no quiero vivir
bajo la junta militar por eso salgo a la
calle aunque tenga miedo lucharemos
juntos contra los militares
el aumento de la violencia se produce
después de que los manifestantes
políticos derrocados por el golpe
prometieron continuar lo que llamaron la
revolución haciendo eco de los llamados
del movimiento de protesta a favor de
una democracia federal que otorgue a los
grupos étnicos minoritarios un papel
crucial en el gobierno de mi amar el más
reciente informe entregado por la
asociación para la asistencia de presos
políticos sobre el número de muertes a
consecuencia de los actos de represión
señala que al menos 125 personas han
fallecido desde el inicio de las
manifestaciones en américa latina' una
jueza de bolivia dictó cuatro meses de
prisión preventiva para la ex presidenta
interina jan ideales se llevará a cabo
la investigación para determinar si la
ex mandataria y dos de sus exministros
acusados de sedición y terrorismo son
los responsables de la violencia que
atravesó el país a finales de 2019 y que
condujo a la renuncia de evo morales- de
la presidencia marina sardenya nos
amplia
la justicia de bolivia en pone cuatro
meses sino seis como pidió la fiscalía
de prisión preventiva al ex presidente
interina jeanine áñez acusada de
sedición y terrorismo por los hechos que
condujeron a la salida anticipada del ex
mandatario evo morales- a finales de
áñez detenido desde la madrugada del
sábado acusó al partido izquierdista más
de su persecución como hemos denunciado
el más decidido y el sistema judicial
obedece me envían cuatro meses detenida
para esperar un juicio por un golpe que
nunca ocurrió desde aquí llamó a bolivia
a tener fe y esperanza un día entre
todos levantaremos una bolivia mejor el
ex ministro de justicia álvaro coimbra y
el antiguo responsable de energía
rodrigo guzmán también permanecerán en
la cárcel durante cuatro meses una
decisión que divide al país que prepara
marchas masivas tanto a favor como en
contra de la medida
los partidarios de agnès denuncian un
ajuste de cuentas político
del gobierno autocrático presidido por
luis arse y conducido políticamente por
evo morales- de ejercitar terrorismo de
estado en el conjunto de la sociedad
mientras que las víctimas del golpe de
estado hablan de justicia ahora yo pido
justicia que se haga justicia
mi hijo se llamaba juan martín tenía 18
años al menos 36 personas fallecieron
durante la crisis política y social que
atravesó el país a finales de 2019
cuando los partidarios del ex presidente
morales depuesto por la cúpula militar
tras acusaciones de fraude electoral se
enfrentaron a las fuerzas de seguridad
una violencia por la que ahora la
justicia boliviana pide aclarar
responsabilidades
y así llegamos al final del informativo
recuerde que también puede seguirnos en
nuestro sitio web france24 puntocom nos
vemos más adelante que esté con nosotros
ya vienen más noticias
[Música]